do we agree thean right verse it's not
do we
[Music]
agree Allah not for have a son not my
problem that's your problem your problem
problem why are you deleting translation
relax yeah I am a messenger of your Lord
to give you a righteous
okay son of wait it's not perfect it's
not perfect right be perfect excuse me
we don't want to be on camera before
before before before she read for
you before she for
you
does Ali Ali must son read Ali me me
read read my
book wa I'm Arabic speaker I don't I
Allah said
okay have you got aook have you got a
book have you got a book yes Quran you
write a quan you write the Quan have you
translated the Quran I'll translate
Quran yeah some some have you have you
translated full Quran argument here let
me read I'm not story I'm reading Quan
actually I'm reading and clearly son
Surah let me say Surah 19 so who's ly
Surah 19 Surah 19 Surah
Ali who should follow I don't care we
don't I don't speak Arabic I'm reading
English the I am okay I
amanf Ali and Jesus is called the holy
son night holy son okay so holy no
problem am I ly something you are
misting no the holy son do Son of God
does it say are you going to speak to me
or you going to digress excuse me are
you going to speak to me are you
speaking to me does it say stand say it
say not ly not lying say all right
that's hly wait wait let me finish let
me finish it says holy sunay right that
mean Son of God wait wait it says holy
son holy son yeah all right is there
anyone holy apart from God there holy
yes wait who okay the cab is Holy
which which
which which Quran can the book be stupid
wait wait wait wait
wait only God Only God the B holy no
inspired by man inspired by God Only God
holy only God righteous no
bookan just just digressing excuse me
you want to speak to them or speak it to
me I know you for
you you deleted 100 other
translations you going to let me speak
are you going question you are lying
against the Quran why in the Quran in
the
Quran say I'm lying
yeah read read it out read it out read
out read it
out can you speak or just read of time
[Music]
look
outan 19
verse just wasting time chanity the
Christian preachers are dying they're
looking for anything like literally
there was a Christian earlier on you're
going to see in the video he came to me
he said is the name Yahweh in the Quran
I said why is a conditional for the name
of yah he has to be in the he said yes I
said show me where Jesus called God
Yahweh it's not in the Bible okay then
he start struggling this guy now he
tried to say means holy for the sake of
argument say it's holy right but the is
called
holy in the Bible many Prophet call
Righteous the only righteous is God in
their Bible so therefore this person why
he's doing because Christianity is dying
he's like looking for anything to uh
score points but they keep uh um what do
they call it failing miserably they
cannot refute Islam they're looking for
anything imagine one of them said to me
he said in the Quran Allah told us to
worship
Jesus in the Quran show in the Quran
we in the Quran even see let know so
there's different between the prophets
and Messengers yes they don't commit
sins however they fall they do fall into
shortcomings there's a
in Prophet Muhammad
s said if Allah hold me accountable and
Jesus he will punish us without doing
any wronging to us why this explained
because regardless how much you worship
Allah you will never be able to fulfill
Allah's right that's why in the Quran we
have the in Islam we have the concept of
seeking forgiveness after the prayer
what we do after we finish what we
do why we say I was not doing I was not
doing sin I was doing a prayer because
regardless how much you try to pray
perfectly you will never be able so how
you make it up for shortcomings during
the prayer forgetfulness other than that
by seeking likewise seeking shows the
signs of humbleness which all of us
including the prophets and Messengers
even the Mal humbles themselves to Allah
waala so seeking forgiveness of Allah
doesn't mean that we are we commit sin
or Prophet Muhammad
s is a sinner because one of the
argument Christian try to use they said
to you Prophet Muhammad is
a why because because in the Quran
Allah
said Muhammed vers
19 acknowledge no there's no one worthy
of worship in truth except Allah and
seek forgiveness for yourself and for
the Believers M female say look no it's
not sin because seeking forgiveness
doesn't not mean you're a sinner what it
means you humble yourself to your
creator so they say look Jesus is not
sinner sinless no prophets and
Messengers all of them are sinless in a
way they don't not fall into sin
intentionally
likewise however they do for into
shortcomings as human
nature so the Christians now what they
doing even they go and against their own
Bible for the sake to try disprove Islam
he doesn't not mind to go against un
belief for the sake of this proven Islam
and I give you glad side in dear
brothers and sisters alhamdulillah six
people accepted Islam on Friday and the
Friday before it likewise alhamdulillah
so when you speak to people who have a
sound reasoning sound natural
inclination naturally they'll be
inclined toward Islam because the one
who created sound intellect and a sound
natural inclination is Allah is the same
one who who sent down Islam that's why
they go in line Christianity doesn't
make any sense that's why look what
Christians are doing now CH harassing us
because the Christian will never be able
to stand before the camera and say God
is
Jesus second let me finish Jesus is God
the father is God the holy spirit is God
so therefore there's only one God
speaking no what Jesus Is God is he
fully God yes so we have one God that's
it no no no we have fully God but
there's another God so we have another
God no no no there's still one God is
like which school you been to 1 + 1 + 1
is equal three if you is equal one you
have to tell us which school You' been
to to inform the government to shut
blood down cuz this school is causing a
problem okay that's why Christianity is
dying in the west Islam is spreading
alhamdulillah even though there's a huge
war against Islam in the mainstream
media but people still accepted Islam
they say Islam Force woman to ex Force
women majority of revert in the West
word are women
sub they plan and Allah plan and Allah
is the best of the planet Allah imagine
you see English wom French woman German
wom American women they have everything
Freedom yet they choose Islam and they
were or or Subhan Allah no one forcing
them but on the other hand they say the
Muslim man forc their woman to wear
hijab where in the west the the Western
woman accepted Islam and they wear hijab
without no one forcing them for Allah to
show his the
a how you become
Muslim that's but what I'm saying
someone else other guy you're right
you're right you see you got place to
worship right I got toship likewise the
Christians they got place toship yes the
moment a must is built in any country
you you've got a right toship worship
once once they allow you in their
country to bring your religion they've
got a right and it's not down to the
Christian people to lose their faith is
down to the government that sold out
their faith in the beginning because
once if if if if you start building big
Christian Church in Arabia then it's
going to be dominant as well because no
it's not because why we have we have
churches in Egypt but dominant dominant
no no we have churches in Egypt here the
no no wait the problem here is not about
the government allowing it the problem
here the youth I'm AG the young people
are not no no no for to put the
government side young people now know
that Christianity doesn't make any sense
they know that doesn't make they know
they know Christianity Christianity is
not H me Christianity is not a religion
it's a way of life Christianity is been
a church that's it leave the religion
out of it for now this country has been
a Christian country for thousands of
years right thousands thousand how many
how many years could Christianity came
to England maybe
uh so say let's say 1,800 something okay
fine so 1,
1,8 1,800 years of Christianity then 100
Years of M in this country no no over
100 years 100 tell me 100 years MOS was
buil by English in 18 18 wait wait which
one this one that was a that was a
Indian that was a like no this one was
an English guy he was a re he the
mus no no no what year what year was
that because it's only recent Muslim the
first Muslim musk no problem 19 1925
okay no problem so once once they
allowed a musk to be built in this
country they've already sold their right
cuz cuz once he sold your right to
another religion to build there a place
of worship then you already give them a
home no you're going to have family
right your argument is incorrect no no
no no no listen because I can't put
Egypt allow the more must the more must
that's buil in this country is the more
this country become an Islamic State no
it's
not the
more I know I and because you got a
place of worship also the children need
need family right cuz the men are going
to worship now their wives going to need
to come over to support them now the
children also need to go to school so
are you blaming the government no no no
I'm not
BL I'm just saying the people the Govern
the people is greater cuz right now
everyone's turning into atheist and
especially the white people that used to
be the Christians in the church yeah now
they're forsaken they're forsaking their
church right and becoming mlim they they
have a right they have they have a right
to choose because they're human being
right they're being
and because they have a right to choose
they can be SE they can be
gay they can be whatever they want to be
now because of the liberalism that this
country has become now Muslim are
becoming a dominant religion in the west
why based on population growth no no no
no no that's that's that's not true
that's not true you can disagree with me
but you you know this argument me this
argument has been used by J I'm actually
agreeing with you no
you have a right to you have a right to
speak no no no wait the reason that
Islam no no no the reason Islam is
spreading in the west because Islam is
the only religion that is standing firm
and gu
the let me finish let me finish you have
let me finish don't tell what respect
the reason sorry about thatle sorry
Uncle I'll allow you to finish though
that's cuz you never allowed me to I did
but you don't want to finish I'm going
allow you to finish but make sure you
finish you don't want to finish bro
anyway the point here is the reason that
Islam is spreading in the west because
there's a hiden agenda by hidden
organizations to destroy our human
nature politics let me finish let me
going to let me finish let me finish I'm
not talking about politics I'm talking
about reality agend destroy to destroy
let me finish to destroy our human
nature the only religion that is
standing firm and gu it is Islam so the
Western the English man English woman
likewise when you comes to the Oneness
of God that's the most important part
the Oneness of Allah when you look to
the concept of the Oneness of Allah in
Islam it makes perfect sense it goes in
line with the sound resoning natural
inclination when you look at
Christianity and Judaism literally you
have to struggle with your own brain to
accept it so therefore people they
becoming more learning they studying
more discovering more they see Islam is
a religion that if you follow it you
will have a way of life Christianity is
not a way of life Christianity is only
for the church therefore Ro dictate the
Creator will not give us solusion only
for a specific place the Creator will
give us something for everything
in I'm asking your favor okay
one not Muslim as
an are you married are you married are
you
married are you married
do us favor please do us favor for
the you have to lose your to Mar you
know I would I would I please we give
you money we
you I would but watch look at this look
at
this let me
said
many sorry okay for example yeah for
example I'm going to make a proposition
to like to the conion no no no no no no
no no no as a as a Hebrew israelit no no
no no no listen listen listen listen I
don't want you to say nothing as an
Hebrew isite we we I I would make a
proposition so if we had a if we had a
mus or or whatever we choose to call it
um a a synagogue whatever whatever a
temple whatever the Hebrew Israelites
Temple right if we have a beautiful
Hebrew Israelite temple in in in in in
in the west like in England for black
people like my complex black people no
no no no no for just us who's us like
when I listen to
I understand I'm giving you an example
remember religion remember remember
remember like Muslim like Islam is for
all people right because Allah is for
all so Allah is for
all and that's Islam that's Islam that's
that's
Islam look when you're speaking everyone
respect you enough to listen but if if
for if we be build a temple now for just
black people listen to what I'm saying
cuz remember your religion is for all
I'm not disagreeing with that but if we
should build a big black Temple for just
black people in this country then we
would have a we would have a place to
worship there is in White City there is
a church only for black people it's like
next are you live there all Africans
there black people church is next to
White go to White City I don't Church
you go there only African there
there's there's different there's
different types of worship during the
within the Muslim Community
right you said if we have a church only
for or Temple only for black people I
gave you a living example of a church
only for black people which is in White
City America have you didn't give me the
address cuz I want to know I want to
know address address 25 White City okay
your religion yeah it allows your
religion your your religion allow
many different ethnicity from many
different um backgrounds some are some
people are genuinely nice people some
people are not really nice people so so
some people are going to let down your
religion and some people are going to
build it up like the sh the Sunni and
the sh they might not agree right but
it's the same religion HEB is that's
what I'm saying HEB because we go
because we go according to the
scriptures you have groups with you yeah
know I know I know you have groups
we can Rectify that but because because
so why not United then what then but
then it takes one to unite listen sh it
takes one to unite all yeah but it takes
it takes one it takes Muhammad it takes
Muhammad to unite the
Arabia it takes Christ to unite the the
Jews and the Christians together as one
it takes one person at all time so even
even though even though we might even
though we might be dis disunited because
without a separation they can't be a
gathering right I respect you and honor
you and I and and because you guys have
have M many musk in this country we
don't have many mus many mus okay what
okay the government they not forcing no
one no no no it's
fine this the governmentus
the governments are not forcing no
Christian to sell their churches okay we
are buying churches we bought one East
London we bought one in atin the
brothers recently we bought one in
German Town so why church are been sold
to the Muslim because the Christians
left Christianity Christianity doesn't
not resolve the problems we are facing
in our time the only religion that fac
in detail is the Islam
because Islam from Allah the almighty
even Hebrew Israelite doesn't know
resolve the problem Hebrew Israelite
increase the problem Hebrew Israelites
is a racist way or
religion sh don't say
that don't say we're racist don't say
we're racist do you be honest do not
believe a devil
that you're not white I'm not white but
I care about white people I care about
you I do care about white people youil I
care about white people enough to bring
them back to Christianity do you believe
the white man is a devil listen listen
listen I'm asking you do you believe the
white man is a devil listen you're not
going to put words in my m i I'm asking
I didn't say no words you're not going
to or you're not going to put you
believe I'm I'm an ew Israelites I don't
have to say what they say no problem I'm
asking you don't have to say what
like have to
say I don't have to share my all right
no
comment I don't have
to com to you're trying to mess up a
beautiful day no no no no no list it's
good to be honest because why I'm show
to is ask I never ask say brother look
my is
is is a part of the problem too it's
wrong it's wrong to say that the white
man hasn't got the right to defend his
people he say that no no no no I'm
saying I'm
saying it would be wrong for me to say
that the white man hasn't got the right
to defend his ask you that devil white
man have his right to you believe the
white man is
devil do you think the white man is
I don't believe the white man is a
devil I believe that I believe that
Islam is a
devil I believe that the Quran
okay
problem anyway brother brother okay if
Islam is devil what Islam teach us to C
the devil thean explain that to me is
devil wait wait wait Allah tell us to
curse
every wait Allah tell us to curse every
type of devil okay the biggest devil
which is Lucifer Allah tell us to curse
it the most the S the devil of evil
Lucifer correct
Lucifer I do not age you for the
devil you work with the
devil and before Christianity before
Abraham
you seem like very uncomfortable yeah
because
you're trying to leave like you're my
brother you've always you always brother
there's no doubt there's no doubt that I
have to accept I have to accept Islam in
this country there's no doubt because
there's no ISL like like if you know in
China there's some places where they're
tearing down the mus if it was if it's
down to me as a as a as as an Israelite
right we would take back our castles and
every every month that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying so so the
cast you know what I
mean you see like this is know this
country old this country has
old you don't believe in Christianity no
I don't believe he doesn't believe
Christianity is for the white man you
know Christianity is for the white okay
wait wait you know
you all know you
know devil so there's there's three
major religions in this in this earth
ask is Christianity devil or not so
there's listen listen is a Christianity
Buck let
me he knows where I'm going he
knows you know speak everyone listens
yeah respect brother then is
Christianity or not is rain I I
Christianity devil or before I go Muslim
Muslim Judaism devil Muslim devil Muslim
Christianity Judaism it's devil yeah all
three religions I already told you yeah
okay so why you want to why you want to
bring a white man to the devil if you
love if you care a white man why you
want to bring to the devil the white man
is my master not your master why not why
not don't say that don't say that don't
say that don't say that don't say that
Jamaican man yeah Jamaican are free
people
Jama about Jama fake Jamaica never say
this Jamaica
say have
you they it for
no no no you don't know nothing about me
you don't know nothing about you don't
know I
Allah Jama never say what man was my
master say that I don't know what
happened to you today okay we are he's a
free man you know our true Master is
Allah waala you know he's our the master
you know Islam slavery let me clarify
that there two typ slavery
there is servitude which happen in the
war and there is one which is blame
worthy which Islam wants and gets which
European were involved when they went to
Africa and kidnapped black people and
enslaved them this go against Islamic
teaching the only time servitude is
allowed in Islam in a time of War proper
War the Muslim leader has four choices
one of them to keep the prisoners as a
servant or to let them go free so even
keeping them as a servant it is not
obligatory in Islam because the the
scholars of Islam said originally human
being are free Allah created Adam as a
free man okay servitude occurred after
you understand that Allah guide him
aldah for Islam look he agree that Islam
is spreading by because we they call it
because we procreate no because people
are accepting Islam because the only
religion that makes perfect sense the
concept of the Oneness of Allah likewise
the only religion the extending firm
against the hidden agenda Freemason
other organizations that want to destroy
our human nature is Islam alhamdulillah